in this video I want to take a look back
at the period from 1802 1848 kind of
from a bird's eye view this is a huge
time in American history in 1800 the
United States was just a fledgling
nation less than 20 years out from
winning its independence political
parties were in their infancy
infrastructure was practically
non-existent and one disastrous war with
a world power the likes of Great Britain
or France could easily have wiped it out
but fast forward to 1848 less than fifty
years later and by then the United
States had developed a great deal as a
unified independent nation it occupied a
vast amount of territory in North
America trains and steam ships
transported goods to distant markets
factories turned out textiles and
politics saw the rise and fall of not
one but two party systems despite all
this growth in 1848 the United States
was just 12 years away from the onset of
an incredibly bloody civil war that
pitted southern states against the US
government it seems like quite a
contradiction over the course the first
half of the 19th century was the United
States developing a unified national
identity or were its geographic sections
developing a divided regional identity
barely held together by the Constitution
what we're doing here really is asking a
historical question if you saw this on
the AP exam the question might look
something like this explain the extent
to which politics economics and foreign
policy promoted the development of the
American identity from 1802 1848 sounds
pretty fancy-schmancy but we can
translate that to a simpler question
what tied the United States together as
a country over the course of 1800 to
1848 and what split it apart to answer
this let's review what happened in this
period in these three areas politics
economics and foreign policy and see if
we think they contributed to a unified
American identity or a divided
regional identity and just to remind you
this is a big overview of the historical
developments from 1802 1848 I'm not
going to take a lot of time here to
explain everything in depth but if you
find that you're unfamiliar with some of
the things we discuss make a note of it
and then go back to review that concept
when you've got some time okay
as we said about to answer this question
let's just brainstorm some of the major
political economic and foreign policy
developments in this time period it
doesn't have to be an exhaustive list of
everything that happened just some key
highlights I'll suggest a few but feel
free to pause the video and see what you
can think of on your own all right what
happened in politics well there was the
development of political parties first
the Federalists and the Democratic
Republicans and then later on they were
replaced with the Jacksonian Democrats
and the Whigs there was the expansion of
the right to vote to almost all white
men in this era and there were a lot of
political controversies too that come to
mind or the Missouri Compromise
and the nullification crisis so which of
these things contributed to a unified
identity and which contributed to a
regional identity well I would say that
the Missouri Compromise and the
nullification crisis were both examples
of regional identity trumping American
identity since they concerned the
balance of power between free states and
slave states and whether states or the
federal government should have the final
say the expansion of the right to vote
seems like a point for unification to me
since it celebrated American democracy
as the birthright of white men from all
states on political parties I might say
this is inconclusive they're elements of
both unity and division among them since
political parties weren't exclusively
defined by region in this time period
but they were often defined by how much
power they believed the federal
government should have compared to the
states okay on to economics major
developments in this time period include
the market revolution the controversy
over terror
and the increasing separation between
the economies of the industrial north
and the agricultural south of these I
would say that separate economic systems
definitely promoted or divided regional
identity the controversy over tariffs
also promoted divisions in that southern
plantation owners thought that tariffs
gave advantage to northern manufacturers
at their expense the market revolution
is a bit tricky to categorize it
promoted some ties between the sections
because it became easier to conduct
business over long distances due to
innovations and transportation and
communication but a lot of the major
networks of transportation and
communication connected the north and
the west to each other not the south
lastly foreign policy in this era there
was the war of 1812 as well as westward
expansion that caused conflict with
Native Americans and with Mexico I'd say
that the war of 1812 was a force that
brought Americans together in a shared
sense of patriotism following victories
like the Battle of New Orleans the
westward expansion was a bit more of a
mixed bag in general most white
Americans supported the concept of
manifest destiny and thought that the
removal of Native Americans for that
purpose was justified but westward
expansion also led to regional conflict
because the admission of new states into
the Union threatened the balance of
power between free and slave states in
Congress so based on the evidence we've
gathered here let's see if we can
formulate a thesis statement to answer
this question the prompt is asking us to
evaluate the extent to which
developments in politics economics and
foreign policy promoted the development
of an American identity so I think that
we want to approach this not as an
either/or or a yes/no question but
rather a question of degree I would say
that the overall evidence here points to
a divided regional identity with a few
points of view
Americans agreed that the United States
needed to expand and that democracy was
the birthright of all white men but in
almost every other aspect of politics
economics and foreign policy they were
divided along sectional lines would you
come to the same conclusion remember
this is only one way of answering this
question you may have come up with some
different examples or you might
interpret these examples in a different
way than I have and that's okay
the next step now that you've evaluated
your evidence and composed your thesis
statement is to think about how you
might arrange the thoughts you've
gathered here into an argumentative
essay